Feeling groggy, tired or
unmotivated in the afternoon?
Using coffee, soda and
energy drinks
we often try to push
through the dreaded long day
yawning through the hours
and fighting the fatigue.
But it just so happens that
the solution
is the very thing we've been trying
to avoid all along,
sleep.
Truth is, the power nap
is perhaps the most effective way
to rejuvenate your brain.
There are four main stages of
your sleep cycle.
The first two are relatively
light sleep,
while the third brings you
into a deep slumber.
The final stage known as
rapid eye movement,
or REM for short,
is where most of your dreams begin.
The benefits of napping are
tied to the length
of time in which you are asleep.
Naps 30 minutes in length
generally only allow time to enter
these first stages.
In stage 1, slow eye movement begins
and if woken you often feel as though
you didn't even sleep.
But as you continue into
stage 2
your brain begins to inhibit processing.
and ignores external stimuli that
it deems non-dangerous
in order to relax you
and give you a tranquil sleep.
It also begins memory consolidation,
in which information you learn
is processed.
Waking out of these stages has
shown benefits including;
increased productivity,
increased cognitive function,
enhanced memory,
boosted creativity
and most importantly,
feeling less tired.
Beyond 30 minutes you
enter stage 3
and experience something known as
sleep inertia when awakened.
Because your body is
coming out of a deep sleep,
motor dexterity is decreased
while grogginess and the longing
to go back to sleep increases.
Many people falsely deem naps
non-beneficial for themselves,
but the truth is,
they have simply napped too long.
As the benefits of napping
become clearer
many nap salons have opened
throughout Japan,
where workers can pay to have a
brief lunchtime nap on a daybed
to increase alertness at work.
So maybe it's about time we all
start sleeping on the job a little more.
Just tell your boss "Science said so".
Got a burning question you want answered?
Ask it in the comments or on
facebook and twitter.
And subscribe for more
weekly science videos.